so we're starting off with triangle abc
here and we see from the drawing that we
already know that the length of a b is
equal to the length of ac or line
segment a b is congruent to line segment
ac and since this is a triangle and two
sides of this triangle are congruent or
they have the same length we can say
that this is an isosceles triangle
isosceles
triangle one of the hardest words for me
to spell i think i got it right and that
just means that two of the sides are
equal to each other now what i want to
do in this video is show
what i want to prove
so what i want to prove here
is that these two and they're sometimes
referred to as base angles these angles
that are that are between one of the
sides and the side that isn't
necessarily equal to it and the other
side that is equal and the side that's
not equal to it i want to show that
they're congruent so i want to prove
that angle abc
proved that angle a
b c i want to prove that that is
congruent to angles a
c b
angle a
c b and so for an isosceles triangle
those two angles are often called base
angles and this might be called the
vertex angle over here and these are
often called the sides and these are or
the or the legs of the isosceles
triangle and these are obviously their
size these are the legs of the isosceles
triangle and this one down here that
isn't necessarily the same as the other
two you would call the base so let's see
if we can prove that
so we we there's not a lot of
information here just that these two
sides are equal but we have in our
toolkit a lot that we know about
triangle congruency so maybe we can
construct two triangles here that are
congruent and then we can use that
information to figure out whether this
angle is congruent to that angle there
and the first step if we're going to use
triangle congruency is to actually
construct two triangles so one way to
construct two triangles is let's set up
another point right over here
let's set up another point d
and let's just say that d is the
midpoint of b and c so it's the midpoint
so the distance from b to d is going to
be the same thing as the distance let me
do a double slash here to show it's not
the same as that distance so the
distance from b to d is going to be the
same thing as the distance from
d to c and obviously between any two
points you have a midpoint
and so let me draw
let me draw a segment a d
let me draw a segment a d and what's
useful about that is that we've now
constructed we have now constructed two
triangles and what's even cooler is that
triangle a b d and triangle a c d they
have this side is congruent this side is
congruent and they actually share this
side right over here they actually share
that side right over there so we know
that triangle we know that triangle
a b d triangle a
b d
we know that it is congruent to triangle
a c d
to triangle a c d and we know it because
of sss side side side you have two
triangles that have three sides that are
congruent or they have the same length
then the two triangles are congruent and
what's useful about that is if these two
triangles are congruent then their
corresponding angles are congruent and
so we've actually now proved our result
because the corresponding angle to abc
in this triangle
the corresponding angle to this is angle
acd in this triangle right over here
so that we then know that angle
abc
is congruent is congruent to angle to
angle a
c b so that's a pretty neat result if
you have an isosceles triangles a
triangle where two of the sides are
congruent then they're base angles these
base angles are also going to be
congruent now let's think about it the
other way can we make the other
statement if the base angles are
congruent do we know that these two legs
are going to be congruent so let's try
to construct a triangle and see if we
can prove it the other way
so i'll do another triangle right over
here
let me draw another one just like that
that's not that pretty of a triangle so
let me draw it a little nicer
i'm going to draw it like this
i'm going to call this let me do that in
a different color so i'll call that a
i will call this b
i will call that c right over there and
now we're going to start off with the
idea that this angle angle abc is
congruent to angle acb
so this is where they have the same
exact measure and what we want to do in
this case we want to prove let me draw a
little line here to show that we're
doing a different
a different idea here we're saying
if the if these two sides are the same
then the base angles are going to be the
same we proved that now let's go the
other way if the base angles are the
same do we know that the two sides are
the same so we want to prove
we want to prove
that
segment a b is congruent to segment ace
or ac is congruent to a b
to a b or you could say that this length
of segment ac which we would denote that
way is equal to the length
is equal to the length of segment a b
these are essentially equivalent
statements so let's see once again in
our toolkit we have our congruency
theorems but in order to apply them you
really do need to have two triangles so
let's construct two triangles here and
this time instead of defining another
point at the midpoint i'm going to
define
i'm going to define d
i'm going to define d this time
as the point that if i were to go
straight up the point that is
essentially if if you view bc as
straight horizontal if you the point
that goes straight down from a and the
reason why i say that is there's some
point
there's some point you could call it an
altitude that
intersects bc at a right angle and there
there will definitely be some point like
that and so if it's a right angle on
that side if that's 90 degrees then we
know that this is 90 degrees as well
now what's interesting about this
well and let me write this down so i've
constructed
i've constructed a d
a d
such that
such
that
a d
a d is perpendicular to b c
is perpendicular to bc and you can
always construct an altitude essentially
you just have to make a bc lie flat on
the ground and then you just have to
drop something from a and that'll give
you point d you can always do that with
a triangle like this
so let's so what does this give us so
over here we have an angle an angle and
then a side in common
and over here you have an angle that
corresponds to that angle an angle that
corresponds to this angle and the same
side in common and so we know that these
triangles are congruent by aas angle
angle side which we've shown is a is a
valid congruent postulate so we can say
now that triangle
triangle
abd a
b
a b d
is congruent to triangle a c d
a
a c d
and we know that by angle
angle side this angle and this angle and
this side this angle and this angle on
this side and once we know these two
triangles are congruent we know that
every every corresponding angle or side
of the two of the two triangles are also
going to be congruent so then we know
that a b is a corresponding side to ac
so these two sides
these two sides must be congruent and so
you get a b
you get a
b
is going to be congruent is going to be
congruent to ac
and that's because these are congruent
triangles and we've proven what we
wanted to show if the base angles are
equal then the two legs are going to be
equal if the two legs are equal then the
base angles are equal very very very
useful tool in geometry and in case
you're curious for this specific
isosceles triangle
over here we set up d so it was the
midpoint over here we set up d so it
went directly below a we didn't say that
whether it was the midpoint but here we
can actually show that it is the
midpoint just as a little bit of a bonus
result because we know that since these
two triangles are congruent bd is going
to be bd is going to be congruent to dc
because they are the corresponding sides
so it actually turns out that point d
for an isosceles triangle not only is it
the midpoint not only is it the midpoint
but it is the place where it is a point
at which at which a d or we could say
that a d is a perpendicular bisector of
b of b c so not only does it not only is
ad perpendicular to bc but it bisects it
that d is the midpoint of that entire
base